all right guys this gonna be an awesome
episode I've got Cavour here from Vanek
and we've got a lot to cover we're gonna
touch on all things ETF retail products
and then some cool stories from your
background so I appreciate you coming on
thanks for having me fun to be here
absolutely all right so let's let's get
started with uh you know born outside
the US right and so let's walk through
kind of how your background how you get
to the US and we'll go from there yes
absolutely so I was born in Hungary
which is Central Europe in 1990 and that
is the time when you know communism fell
in Eastern Europe and the my parents
were also in Hungary and my probably the
interesting Bitcoin and digital assets
really did part of the story is that two
generations of my parents suffered on
their various dictatorships first the
National Socialists and in the 40s and
then from the 70s to the 90s under
communism and both of these generations
had issues with their property so their
properties have been confiscated and
they would be would have been very glad
if they had an asset something like
Bitcoin so you know 90s kid I started in
Hungary lived a little bit in Germany
and Italy and then came to the u.s. to
finish up my high school and off all
places Massachusetts at Deerfield
Academy and then went to Williams
College Williams College at Williams
College a triple major then mathematics
sociology and German I was Bitcoin class
of 2012 and I was class of 2014 and and
otherwise in and Matt and so did a lot
of work and on distributed systems and
and disc with mathematics and graph
theory and that's how I found Bitcoin
that's amazing Bitcoin class of 2012 I
haven't heard that one yet so I think
we're gonna have to steal that one so
let's talk about your family grows up in
Hungary right you ever see have that
experience and before we were talking
about Bitcoin transactions early on in
Central Europe didn't exactly involve
coinbase or any these other exchanges
how are people actually transacting
Bitcoin at the time yeah that's actually
super interesting question so I was I
was at the Budapest Technical University
and
one of my friends was telling about this
thing called Bitcoin and it was about to
send something like $80 worth of money
to a Romanian dude who has never met on
Western Union and the plan was that he
sense this $80 this guy who has no idea
about and he's going to get an email
with his public key and a few days later
in a physical letter he would get his
private key and then he would have
access to this imaginary thing on what's
called the blockchain or really Bitcoin
and so that was Bitcoin trading in 2012
and in the same year two exchanges
bitstamp and b2c btc-e have have been
established and in since then we have
come far with over-the-counter trading
high-frequency trading futures contracts
ETS that's almost crazy to me so or not
but but it's even crazier what you've
described right so 2012 first of all why
is your friend in Hungary sending money
to somebody in Romania that they don't
know yeah I mean that's so there was a
Technical University and Hungary is just
famous of producing some of the best
mathematicians and in combinatorics and
distributed systems and so they were
studying he was studying distributed
systems and and one of the one of the
things that we have done together is
looking at how difficult it would be to
destroy the internet you know things
that Eastern European guys are thinking
about in my Budapest Hungary but so the
so we got interested in and sort of like
resistance systems that are resistant to
stress and we found that it takes about
like eighty one percent of you need to
destroy 81 percent of the computers and
the Internet in order shut down the
internet and we were thinking about in
the context of like economics and money
and and and found Bitcoin through
through some of the subgroups that the
university who were studying really
liked practical systems that you know
are in place not in not in theory but in
practice and that's he was like you know
I need to buy this but how do you buy
this and that's how he he knew you just
going to read it and saw blogs and then
found this Romanian guy who's selling
Bitcoin that is absolutely amazing and
so what people were doing is they were
sending one of the keys via email and
then they were literally sending the
private key via snail mail literally a
physical letter with the private key in
it and so me is the recipient I would
receive the email with the public key
mail you know in a physical format with
the private key I could put them
together now I've got access to the
Bitcoin
yeah that's correct and and that was you
know from purchase to settlement it was
probably around five seven days and
geographical distance was probably
around four hundred five hundred miles
if the guy was really in the place where
he stated he was we never figured out he
was at the place but he delivered on on
the obligation the the crazier thing was
that you literally had to put up the
check on Western Union to a person
before any of these things would happen
but yeah that was back on trading in
2004 the crypto community really trust
each other yeah I mean he I think gave
IC systems got a little bit better
absolutely all right so so how do you go
from living in Hungary sending eighty
dollars to random Romanians to working
at Vanek was kind of the path there yep
so I graduated from Williams College and
my degree was in mathematics and well I
reached out to a bunch of people in our
alumni network I'm I'm sort of known to
be a power networker and I really take
networking seriously so I reached out to
a bunch of folks one of our board
members introduced me to yan yan Vanek
who is the CEO of Vanek today and and
the guy's a visionary and he runs a
private company with roughly 50 billion
dollars in assets and from moment one I
I knew that that's where I want to work
so I joined the ETF team at Vanek so my
my responsibilities were a few fold one
of them was building new ets for the
firm so we built some you know contra
founds green bond funds mode divide mode
ETF mirroring warren buffett's
investment strategy we build some IAM
local currency bonds and and and you
know Vanek was specializing to in
providing access to harder to access
area so my job was to kind of do two
non-sexy were
in the background and we also have like
the large client clients and and I think
Morgan Creek is occasionally our clients
and but the lost shops are the lost
shops are asking for the allocation
recommendation or why should you own
gold why should you on emerging markets
and so those were the questions that
I've been fielding and because of my
background in mathematics and then the
pickup in an encrypted about two years
ago I can I'm one and a half two years
ago I refocused completely on crypto and
and basically since then I'm working on
building the right market structure for
exchange-traded products and and and
digital assets related vehicles amazing
so before we get into all the digital
asset ins kind of the exciting sexy
stuff of today VX got a really
interesting background right the company
itself let's walk through you know how
did the company get started and you know
what were some of those early products
like and then eventually into the gold
market but but let's really started kind
of the founding of the company so Vanek
was built in 1955 that that's not
yesterday so it's not one of the older
private asset manager companies and it
was established by john van eck who is a
visionary and he he is built a few
things that are real first in the market
so in the 50s mr. van egg John van egg
that has built the first international
investors fund so after World War two
mr. Vanek was thinking about ways in
which the post-war reconstruction could
be accessed and how an investor from the
United States would benefit from from
the growth that would inevitably take
place and so he built the first
international fund and people like 50s
it was like the International stocks
were like Bitcoin in the in the 50s
people why would you invest in in these
things and the next years to come
international investing picked up and so
that was the first fun and then in the
late 60s mr. Vanek I think he at that
point of time he had a few kids and he
was employed kind of full-time and
decided to do a PhD in economics of all
things because
as our CEO Yan Vanek would say you know
that's the kind of thing that people
have time for in the evening school and
PhD in economics and and mr. Vanek was a
student of ludwig von mises who was a an
Austrian economist and a part-time
professor at NYU and so mr. Vanek called
the gold bog liquidated I think
something like 70 to 80 percent of his
holdings and in 1968 he created the
first gold equity fund in the United
States and you know back then again like
people as the same questions as 13 years
before why the hell would you invest and
in in gold right and and what is gold
good for and and and before the gold
standard was done away gold was fixed
near $35 per ounce and so mr. van I just
created this fund and we we know that
gold sort of like picked up and twelve
hundred dollars an ounce today and and
became an eight trillion dollar market
and then it's the top safe haven asset
today and then kind of the story goes
forward yon Vanacore current CEO took
over and in the 2000s he launched one of
the first of these things called the ETS
and you know ETS became in the u.s.
around four trillion dollar industry and
and provide unprecedented liquidity and
access to harder to access areas and so
yon our CEO has pioneered ETFs and he
built some of the largest gold equity
TSG DX in GD XJ and he also hired a
geologist hired folks from there's a
bunch of international people from and
he also built some of the first iam
equity funds and um equity does really
valid Vanek and build things like mode
and motors are no Warren Buffett like
investing structure and some of the
large municipal bond funds and and and
and a few other products on the on the
country side so areas that were at the
mo at the time
harder to to access for instance like
the Russia Russia investing was really
tough because of sanctions and we built
the fund our sex that provides access to
Russia and we built some of this you
know smaller cap Indonesia Vietnam and
and and and smaller country exposure
funds that people have a hard time
investing in and in a way that would be
liquid and so so you know fast forward
in time about I think Iran we started
conversations like two and a half three
years ago and on the topic we wanted to
see what we can do in the digital assets
and then and so it was it was a natural
for van act to kind of transition and
into it and and what we were like oh
okay so our core competency now is ETS
and you know around thirty five billion
if our forty eight billion is in ETS
we're going to build a Bitcoin ETF and
then learn about this like a whole slew
of things that needs to be put in place
like valuation custody and all these
markets structure questions that we were
not aware of at the moment at that
moment at that time absolutely so let's
talk about you know what is the
parallels that you guys who are one of
the pioneers in kind of gold and gold
ETFs et cetera see with the digital
asset space right so are there any
things that you learned from kind of
being at the forefront of the gold
industry that you're using today or
maybe even thinks you're avoiding yes so
first of all we learned that similarly
to gold
I mentioned valuation before back in the
in the 70s people were in the same same
places with Bitcoin gold markets were
fragmented and no one really understood
like what is the price of Bitcoin right
and so we learned that we would need to
put in place a benchmark that that would
that would be sufficient for for pricing
Bitcoin for institutional investors so
through our German subsidiary MB is
which is a you benchmark registered
indexing entity we launched regulated
indices and iterated but the SEC CFTC EU
regulators on you know is this good
enough to price Bitcoin and and so we we
try
the top 50 markets with our partner
crypto compare which is a UK shop one of
the probably best known shops were
providing a curd that own crypto and so
Ambus teamed up with crypto compare and
created these benchmark so that was you
know pricing and valuation was one of
the things and then secondarily we knew
that you know derivatives markets are
gonna be built around physical things
that are traded or know as physical as
Bitcoin gets but like sure enough
futures were futures contracts by CBOE
and CM e were at that time built and you
know we are our commodity traders Vanek
were instrumental in building some of
the the first gold and commodity
contracts so we learned for instance
that cash delivered contracts or or
actually you know the an improved
version of futures contracts and a lot
of people talk talk about physical to
physically deliver a Bitcoin futures but
a cash delivered futures so in the 70s
there were physically delivered futures
because if you hadn't you know a
thousand barrels of oil you actually
have to go to the port and take your
thousand barrels of oil and then traders
are like well you know I don't know if I
want to have a thousand barrels of oil
delivered so they created something
called the cash delivered future so and
started rolling contracts and having
this type of obligations that are never
delivered so we immediately understood
the cash delivered futures like as they
exist today are actually an improvement
and they are useful so those are one of
the things that two of the things
actually doing wheeling absolutely no so
so fascinating so let's go into what an
ETF is like ETF 101 right so I know
nothing about ETFs pitch me on what is
an ETF and why are they important so
liquidity is the single key word why ETS
are important and so an ETF is basically
a stock stocks plus a stock plus a
mutual fund equals an ETF so mutual fund
is generally a vehicle that has that
trades and that can pool assets and
provides it's a pooled investment
vehicle that investor different larger
amounts of investors can can put money
into and we have mutual funds on
emerging markets the sp5
hundred and a bunch of other things and
mutual funds are sort of like word and
invention or innovation in the 70s that
you can invest with other people unlike
what you do kind of in a private equity
basis you go yourself and not with
others and the the tough part of that
was that mutual funds are not
transparent so they you don't know the
exact amount of holdings during the day
and often during the month so you just
don't know about the mutual fund manager
holds and you put your trust into the
man into the manager that they do the
right thing
ETFs is as adds the aspect of a stock to
the mutual fund so ETF by definition is
that it's exchange-traded fund so it's
trades on an exchange like a stock you
have every 15 seconds you have a price
deck on where it is and at the end of
the day you also have the holdings
published issuers need need to publish
their holdings on the daily basis and
the cool thing is at the end of the day
you can always buy 4 p.m. US time for
your CTS at an ETF at nav and any nav is
and that asset value so every day at the
every at the end of every day you know
the exact value of the fund holdings and
you can you can transact in that and the
reason why so why is this gonna so this
is what an ETF is and how do they work
well ETFs are securities that issue
shares so it is say an ATF issues a
hundred thousand shares and they what
then happens is company is called
authorized participants like in larger
very houses Goldman's JP Morgan's large
companies of the world idea underlying
of stocks of an of an exchange-traded
fund and exchange it for the share of an
ETF so why is that important for for
instance for the S&P if I just use the
S&P 500 as an example if you bought the
the S&P 500 stock by stock they would be
it would be really hard to do if you
wanted to replicate that performance now
if you if an a large company but does
the work for you and buys the the
underlying assets and you can just
exchange it to the share the II that
makes the purchasing process more
efficient
cheaper and these companies hold large
inventories of of the underlying assets
so that means that they will add
liquidity whenever you would like to
issue or redeem shares of of a fund so
basically you get an extra set of
liquidity from from authorized
participants who are incentivized to buy
and sell securities and liquidity is the
single most important keyword and
investing especially in the crypto
markets where if you put a lien on a
thirty million dollar order and that may
impact the price of something and say
Bitcoin fairly significantly so so ETF
by definition helped with liquidity
management and yeah so they're just and
they're there's what I call them ETS are
sort of like the thrust minimized
version of stock investing because all
these parties that are like the APS are
competing with each other they don't
need to trust each other the investor
doesn't need to trust the fund manager
like the hedge fund manager and mutual
fund manager and and and and sure enough
ETF death pickup absolutely well what
are the downsides to an ETF right there
there's a bunch of pros obviously
especially in crypto but but what are
the downside is actually having these
products available to retail investors I
I see very like compared to the current
landscape if we are talking about
digital asset specifically I don't see
many downsides because ETFs add
liquidity they have and lucky I'm a cave
I see requirements generally the
custodians insures the underlying asset
and and and again it's the most Restless
form of investing in the in the crypto
space the possibly the you know what
when I when I have conversations with
some of the top swords like older Brett
clearing guys they don't like the idea
if it was some asset manager
accumulating large amounts of Bitcoin
and sort of sort of like acting on
behalf of their customers and because
it's kind of against the spirit of
Bitcoin and you know I think think
myself often it isn't it crazy
with launching an ETF on Bitcoin where
when Bitcoin is this sort of like
decentralized retail oriented asset and
and you know some people still prefer to
hold their private keys and and and have
different coal storage solutions or
methods of storing their asset and
that's their preference but other other
folks like say my I don't know my mom
for instance my mom is not very good and
despite the fact that she's from Eastern
Europe she's not very good at
cryptography and she wouldn't be able to
cold store her assets and I wouldn't
want my mom to walk around with it with
a thumb drive of like a million dollars
that wouldn't be safe so an ETF just
kind of adds this component of security
professional asset management around it
and probably weirdly enough and you guys
if you trade crypto you know this you
get tax reporting and other reporting on
your assets which is incredibly hard all
the crypto trading is jurisdiction
dependent today so that knew that extra
tax reporting component is just helpful
absolutely no it's so fascinating
because you know with these ETF products
you get more liquidity you get more
security right there there's some
sophistication some validation
accessions that come with these products
so as you guys saw okay digital assets
are becoming an asset class that we want
to participate in we've got all this
institutional knowledge and experience
from decades of working in other assets
you know gold etc what was the first
thing you guys filed so first we filed
for Vanek was first to file for a
futures based ETF and you might ask why
future is based ETF and so the reason
for that is every month two months you
we see a major hack of some sort
somewhere around the world and and today
there are no custodians and and in the
digital asset space that are you know
full-fledged institutional custodians
that could hold exchange-traded fund
assets at least no one really puts their
balance sheets behind digital asset
activity in a meaningful way I do think
this is a look at the business and we
were gonna see entrance coming in next
few years definitely I would say but no
custodians existed so we said okay
since the there
there are two futures actually first
when we found the futures contract
didn't exist and and so we filed for
this future CTF hoping and that there
were the futures contracts as we have
seen from our commodities experience and
that way what happens in futures land is
that you know at that point of time my
thinking was that if you don't own
Bitcoin directly the best way to own
Bitcoin for institutions is not owning
Bitcoin so by the futures post a margin
that you're using with the futures
commodity merchants and futures
commodity merchants are basically or are
buying and selling the the contract in
clearing houses and you know that way no
one has to worry about actually
physically custody in Bitcoin while you
are getting price exposure either
appreciation or depreciation when you're
getting the exposure true through an ETF
and then you know instead only
institutions could create future so I
was like well we want to make it
available a bit more broadly and and
let's just package it and have our
futures trend commodities trading team
do the work for them in what was the
regulars response to that first filing
right what excitement fear in between
where did they really come out with that
as you guys had conversations with them
so first when we file the ETF and they
call that we got as hey guys the bacon
futures market doesn't exist yet so we
got rejected on that and then I mean
we're not the kind of people who give up
like and we kind of show that in the
gold space as well so surely enough we
sort of expected the the zebu and the
CME contracts to come out at your end
2017 they did come out we refiled
futures contracts and I existed and and
we're like oh you know we're ready and
at the same time like we sort of
iterated our indices that we built with
them says we have the largest data set
and in the world today to to price
Bitcoin and we have sold a valuation
problem long ago so here we can price it
there's futures contract pricing from
SIBO and CME we have you know a
secondary level pricing from MVIS
50 platforms you're also kind of working
with some OTC guys on pricing and and
then filed again for it and then the
response was that you guys should
withdraw it because the the futures
market is not mature enough there's only
like 150 to 200 million dollars of
futures trading that's small compared to
other commodities and while I
experienced was that that's not the case
because there are other small like
freight futures electricity futures and
more thinly traded futures that are that
have ETFs on it that's fine you know we
we were just gonna work through your
questions and then so there was just
ever moving target and so so that the
futures effort we just kind of had it
and finally we had to fit through it
again for reasons and we wrote a letter
if you guys are interested in reading
and the audit should actually read this
on like why the futures market is ready
for an ETF and we discussed like why
valuation is there there is an Athlon
there's arbitrage between futures and
spot markets trading is efficient OTC
you guys are amazing or able to trade
avoid spreads and you can you know
sometimes bitcoins rates at a better
spread than the small con through ets
was like okay like the markets already
so so that you know that's so that line
is it's kind of ongoing and we're
working with regulators and then they
some of the things that are now focusing
on is surveillance and they are the
market surveilled
what does that mean right so so are the
market surveilled explain that yeah so
for instance the US equity and futures
markets participants are generally part
of something called this inter
surveillance group it's a group of
exchange is the larger guys are part of
it and what they do is they provide
trade data to parent exchanges and on a
request to the CFTC for instance so this
surveillance means that you are
monitoring for vash trades and potential
illicit activity activities on on your
platform and Nasdaq happens to have
probably one of the most well known
solution called smarts and and that that
monitors the top
manipulation patterns and basically it
gives exchanges assurance that there's
no illicit activity and the activity on
their platforms and they can also report
out to other larger exchanges or
regulators that we have a clean clean
exchange so actually to my crypto
friends I already recommend it to use
March the Winklevoss brothers and german
i use more arts and some of the other
exchanges are looking at it and why is
that important well you know for
instance we don't want something like
Silk Road money hitting an ETF and an
exchanges need to put put in place best
practices through these surveillance
kind of these are just sophisticated
programs that monitor training patterns
that we use otherwise in the equity and
futures market and the goal is to make
the crypto market look exactly the same
and and I think we are actually decently
close like it's probably 70 percent
there which is do you think that it's
important to have that those protections
there because the regulator's need to
see it and it needs to look similar or
do you think that they actually do
protect investors and and there's some
of this you know wash trading and
manipulation acceptor that's happening
and so we need to kind of clean up you
know that volume and the kind of the
trading patterns etc well I mean the
first acid it is important to the
markets need to grow up
we need grown up markets for ATF to come
in and it is important to protect the
large exchanges of the world are
incredibly lucrative businesses and it's
in their best interest to to be clean at
least like 95% of them should be clean
and and they want to be now it's not
it's not just a regulatory cliche in my
opinion because at the end of the day
again you want the same protections from
from like that you experience in the US
and and Western and well devote capital
markets because investment is kind of
funnily enough about it's about trust so
you shouldn't experience someone running
away with your money or you know someone
some exchange trading their books
against you so they can pay their
employees or something like you know
that those things that exchange you just
need to grow up and and they're on a
good path
that no say that makes sense and so how
do you see ETFs and other kind of retail
financial products evolving in the
digital asset space episode of next two
years so the on the retail side so right
now and and and you probably know it
where well like the digital asset space
is primarily retail so people estimate
something like 90 to 95 percent of it is
retail and you know from from
conversations for the larger like OTC
markets and exchanges that I had it it
kind of confirmed that so retail is kind
of served already if you will so these
these the exchanges and platforms just
need to get better with their practices
with respect to products I'm really
hoping that that ETFs can come in place
because what's available right now
doesn't offer the full protection of
what ETS do and I'm gonna give you just
some some examples to this crypto
trading platforms for instance do not
have the best execution type of
principles apply to their their books so
like you know high-frequency market
makers or scalping retail investors on
doing those platforms every second there
there's kind of like best bid and offer
principles on US activity exchanges and
those things should be applied to crypto
platforms and ETF is required to have
that type of protection the whole so am
Ellen cave I see I would actually think
that say that the am on kyc stand is
most established exchanges are amazing
it's actually harder to open it up at
sorry it's let me just phrase it this
way it is easier to open up a German
bank account and I did this a year ago
when I was at Ambus building and this is
in Frankfurt it's easier to open up a
German bank account than getting a level
a Tier three verification from a crypto
exchange I'm not kidding like you need
to take passport photo with your face in
a timestamp in it banks never ask for
that kind of stuff so you know that and
into the Emma on Cave I see stuff is
actually you're very well monitored so
it's it's all in place I'm hoping for
ETF's
and I'm also hoping that some of the
larger players who have regulatory
requirements and they have skin in the
game also come to the market because
right now crypto companies just kind of
enjoyed the their monopoly in the space
and and for that reason they might not
give the best pricing and customer
protection type of things to through
their customers absolutely and it sounds
like today is you guys take a digital
asset really what your focus on
cryptocurrencies Bitcoin specifically
right and - they're highly liquid assets
that operate as a store value me - makes
change one of the show's sponsors is a
company called block estate right and
basically what they have is they've got
a tokenized fund in the real estate
space and so it's backed by you know
real world assets or or equity how do
you think about retail products like
ETFs etc moving away from
cryptocurrencies or at least you know in
an additive way looking at these equity
backed tokens or security tokens do you
think that's the way that's likely to
happen or far away from it where does
that kind of fitting the vision of at
least what you guys are looking at yep
so we're looking at all kinds of assets
for engineers we're located we're
launching a product we're trying to
launch product around Bitcoin now but I
could see the future how we would as the
market develops look at and evaluate
other sort of like security tokens you
mentioned the real estate space is
actually super interesting to me we we
have a real estate ETF that invest in
reads and and I think new REITs are
actually one of the main targets of
these you know tokenized
initiatives that I'm going to cite you
know I welcome a conversation but your
sponsor or really anyone
and then the space regarding REITs or or
anything we've been obviously pitched
around gold because we we're kind of the
gold experts and in the space but I
would say in the future ten years down
the line I would see how ETS would
contain securitized tokens because why
not
the big question there is how liquid are
these things and and how is it trading
that's going to be the single most
important question anywhere and I think
I think one needs to list these two
can set that regulated platforms in
order to kind of get more widespread
adoption and I would also like the ETF
thing is just the kind of the easy way
of going about investing so you don't
have to worry about tax and you know all
kinds of rebalancing and activities that
most of us don't have time for but I
would love to see more developments and
just like user interfaces and apps that
that would be that would provide easier
access and easier regulated access to
these tokens absolutely yeah look it so
you know the black state guys black
estate calm I I want to make sure that
they they get some air time there but
how do you think about other ETF type
applications so think of bitwise right
so we built a large cap index products
with bitwise and and another thing that
they're doing on their own is they've
launched a crypto index ETF right so
whereas a lot of people have gone after
Bitcoin specific ETFs they've said look
why don't we apply for an actual kind of
top ten crypto type index in an ETF
structure how do you think about Bitcoin
only or kind of a single asset ETF
versus these index approaches yep so I
like the bitwise guys and you know Matt
Hogan his friends for a company for a
long time he's like one of the ETF
legends yeah and love the guy loved the
Haunter and they've done a great job at
there working and and I like the fund
that they the private fund that they
have right now I think it's a smart
thing to do and and I hope that they get
traction with the the SEC or with their
multi-asset product I would think just
kind of you know going rationally about
it that a single asset bitcoin type of
ETF would be approved before a multi
asset would be that is the sort of you
know Bitcoin is more established as more
history some of the tokens supplies in
centralization your questions are still
outstanding on on if you look at you
know say the top 10 there there's
questions around arc tokens and
and some investors holding you know 50%
of the supply and asked grow some
something like that and so you know
that's just something to think about and
regulators I think are looking at the
two but just to kind of support the the
bitwise approach to van XM v is actually
was the first one who launched a
multi-asset index and I spent six months
in Frankfurt with our about twenty
people analytics team to do that and
that so so I know I do believe in the
power of diversification and I'm
regardless of who the issuer would be
I'm really hoping that multi-asset
product comes to market the key there is
to make sure that the tokens are clean
and they're liquid so if just on the
indexing stuff and obviously I'm biased
on this I love what MB is and crypto
compared us there's 20 people in
Frankfurt 15 in London it's rated some
basically we have non-academic
investable indices that are or are also
tradable for instance that was super
important for a country funds and okay
ASP 5 it looks good but how do you trade
that and fortunately the SNP 5 feather
is liquid but maybe Vietnam and and the
top digital asset 10 is not liquid so so
if you guys want to check out that at
the end of indices I'm happy to give
more color and but multi-asset approach
is just in diversification so far it
didn't work out the past year for people
because you know all the cores are down
and in 2018 like the the d810 is keeping
an eye on that it's damn like 80%
Bitcoin held up like 60 went down 62%
and yon and I were just our CEO and I
were talking about this there are we
wrote a little piece for our investors
on Bitcoin and we said that we expected
that your Bitcoin lose 80 or 90 percent
of its value and so far is holding up
and fingers crossed and the other
digital assets did not hold up as well
as Bitcoin did and and you know again
I'm biased on this but I'm a Bitcoin guy
so I think there's a there's case for it
and trust minimized
money and and the other tokens are all
dependent on their applications so I
think there's going to be a winner in
the in the payment space whether it's
ripple or Stella lumens there's gonna be
a winner and and sort of asset issuance
and then a terry amigos type of space we
don't know who that is yet and so it's
you know it's interesting to monitor
those and before you know for everyone
winning position there's a hundred that
competes absolutely it is the it's the
ultimate protocol Wars right good to see
kind of who becomes king in each one of
these these applications okay and so one
of the things that recently got a bunch
of attention is Gemini Zelinka lost
twins they launched a regulated stable
coin right so they were one of the first
people who have essentially said look
we're gonna ensure that it's back to one
to one by u.s. dollar we're gonna allow
kind of external third parties to
validate or audit that that is true and
then the US dollar sit in a FDIC insured
State Street account right and so very
similar to I think what you guys have a
neck are doing in terms of trying to
legitimize or professionalize a lot of
these the products that the the tokens
etc how do you think that impacts just
crypto in general you it big deal not a
big deal how should people be thinking
about that yep so getting sort of like
regulatory approval on pretty much
anything is a big deal and getting
regulatory support and regulators
understand more about the space so
that's a that's a good thing I would say
into my you know it would go back to my
keyword what is the liquidity of this
and sure like all data both vocalize
brothers did a great job in general
getting this approval and and trying to
get this product to market and and I
think people look at it favorably and
and and I do suit to I'm interested in
the liquidity profile and you know how
much control really the exchange has and
you can they Frieza can apparently like
and I think it's possible to freeze some
of the assets on been 48 hours
turnaround or something you know that's
not like Bitcoin Bitcoin cannot be
frozen and there was one that was one of
the one of the reasons we were looking
at that this you know trustless
decentralized uncontrolled thing and so
that you know that's that but the other
and the stable Cohen front we've seen
from the success of Tedder
as in people have a varying a paid
companion and Tedder I think they have
done a great job on on on solving the
problems with US dollars and money on on
ramp so no terrorists fast people want
to see their holdings and and in dollars
and and people want to trade a large
amounts of assets and Tedder's created
that market there are questions around
the audits and and I'm excited for you
know those markets to get better and
improve and one one thing that I'm most
excited about probably in the stable
coin space and again I would put Bitcoin
in front of any other stable coin but as
far as stable coins go I you know I read
some things and and heard some things
that Circle is working on on on a stable
coin concept and the I think the
institutions that the circle folks are
working with with our just kind of worth
monitoring and it's worth monitoring new
entrance and and and and so far like the
execution that the circle team has done
on pretty much anything that they they
have was excellent and you know kind of
like how to clean a polo in their
acquisition their OTC desk is excellent
so I'm looking forward to to see some
like competition in the space and what
the circle guys are coming up with
because I would think that you know
sometimes the Winklevoss brothers tend
to do everything like a lot of things
and and they have and you know again
they may have conflicts of interest or
they may not have full resources support
everything but the circle guys kind of
focusing on a few things and and I think
they do have the resources to build
something interesting so I as far as
stable coins go that's that's the one
I'm monitoring that's awesome yeah I
look I found Jeremy in the circle guys
to it to be great at execution as well
and then super thoughtful about kind of
where they deploy resources etcetera so
that's uh that's another validation
there alright so let's do this let's do
with some rapid-fire questions and then
we'll wrap it up with with you asking me
one question first question though is
what do you think is the most
controversial thought that you have in
crypto where the highest number of
people would disagree with you
that's what do you believe that everyone
else is gonna disagree with oh that's
kind of the 0 to 1 Peter Thiel question
is well actually one of my favorite
books so here it is and both corners are
probably gonna dislike me a little bit
for it is my the higher controversial
thought is that the Bitcoin needs an ETF
we are you know just to go with my Game
of Thrones references a lot of people
are looking at Vanegas kind of Castle
black holding the wall of institutional
money and and and I do think that you
know the ETF and ETF comes out then
bitcoin is going to stick around for
probably a century if not longer and the
reason for that and I don't need to talk
too much about that is so if Wall Street
companies support digital assets in a
meaningful way then you now have Wall
Street and crypto kind of going against
government and right now Wall Street is
in the middle so I would actually
encourage crypto companies and that's
what we see to kind of partner up
establish products that are you know
don't don't fit Bitcoin exactly into the
existing capital markets but Bitcoin is
inherently compatible I make it work and
I think that's near the one the one
thing that most people would disagree
with me is bitcoin is an ETF but do you
agree that that's only correct as long
as the ETF doesn't create more liquidity
or more kind of claims on the 21 million
Bitcoin right so so basically as long as
the ETF matches one two one two up to 21
million Bitcoin we're okay but the
second that we start having more claims
than there are Bitcoin we could run into
some trouble that fair I I completely
agree with that and in fact we have
we're sort of what we're trying to do is
and and I can't talk much about our
security and in-custody solutions but we
want so by definition and ETF have to
show its nav so every day the block and
in the Bitcoin
blockchain you can show wallets sizes
and the ETF can show nav so you can show
one-to-one correspondence between a
wallet size and an nav na and we are
committed to doing that we are committed
to basically keep up bitcoins standards
in the space it's awesome alright so
other than Vanek you you cannot answer
via neck what do you think is the most
important company in crypto right now
I'm monitoring the OTC desks interesting
so it's probably the non sexy answer
again and so the so I'm looking at
circle the Arabs Cumberland and Genesis
these guys have been instrumental and in
bringing crypto to the institutional
space and they are instrumental for
exchange-traded products and increased
liquidity and in the space so I would
say the the top so actually maybe let's
just say the OTC firms and I also think
that your Nasdaq surveillance system is
going is actually a bigger deal and
people don't talk about it enough so
Nasdaq smarts and the OTC destory u.s.
OTC that's combined are the ones that
I'm monitoring yeah it's definitely not
a not a popular answer but but I think
are really smart one all right so let's
say you have a magic wand and you can
wave that magic wand and change one
regulation or law what would it be
I'm in the same page with Hester purse
on sort of like the the retail and
institutional investor standards I think
they're BS and will change over time
retail investors should be able to
access private and private investments
and you know Wow when I was in college I
didn't have you know the required amount
of money to be an institutional investor
but I think it was fairly smart to be
able to save it I want to invest into
something or not I expect the so the
individual and retail and institutional
investors Stander's to change over the
next decade yeah so you're talking about
the accreditation standards right in the
idea that you'll you'll appreciate this
because I've gone as far as to say that
actually the
credit Asian standards are as they
currently stand are violating the
American Dream right now so if you think
about yourself moving to the United
States the American Dream is that no
matter where you come from what language
you speak what your background is who
your parents are or where you end up in
the u.s. you should be able to build a
life of wealth right and and and and do
it through your own effort and so
because these laws literally say you
have to be rich to in order to invest in
some of the best investment
opportunities the rich can only get
richer right and we're boxing out or
precluding an entire demographic of
people based on wealth from investing
those opportunities and it's pretty
ridiculous it is indeed I mean I
actually couldn't put it better and I
just you know it hit me in the face when
I started working in the in the
financial services industry couldn't
invest in private securities and I was
like wow that's crazy you know the all
the Silicon Valley VCS are making Bank
based on just very basic probabilistic
bats and and now I don't want to put
them down but there's not much thinking
and many of those investments just
spread it out and look for the next
1,000 next unicorn where as small people
who have you know a few ten thousand
dollars of assets that they would kind
of earn from something like that their
work say that they averaged near portion
or something cannot invest into it the
next Facebook and I think so I some
people again argue with me on this but I
think crypto actually opened up the door
for private investing and you know
definitely like people this younger
people start to have experience what it
means to to invest privately obviously
these crypto projects are and often
there's governance issues there's a
bunch of other things but you know I if
you guys read the the SEC scannin
newsletter
chairman Clayton came out with you know
his views on how we should revisit
investing in private securities and
again I I credit that to crypto and and
and not just our work but the crypto
communities work of showing how
important it is and how much interest
there is and investing in private things
yeah I mean look it to me that the most
ridiculous part about is we're using
wealth as a
signal for intelligence and we should
probably just move to a system where we
actually use intelligence as a signal
for intelligence right and so move to
some sort of knowledge based test or
knowledge based system rather than a
wealth based system but but that's not
neither here here nor there we can go
for hours on that one all right so what
uh what one question do you have for me
okay so since you're probably one of the
most well known guys and in the crypto
crypto investing space and you're doing
a lot for us I'm wondering what are the
three things that you are looking
forward to in the next three to five
years and in crypto and and and what
should we be all monitoring so you know
three things according to Palms for a
beer oh this is a good question all
right so three things I'm excited about
next three to five years one right now
my partners and I are absolutely on a
you know a war path to getting
institutions off of zero right so right
now a lot of these institutional
investors were talking family offices
endowments pensions foundations
sovereign wealth etc had zero exposure
right and the idea that you can have
zero exposure to the best performing
asset class over the last five years and
it's just pretty insane
right and so we don't think that they
should go and put 500 basis points right
we don't think that we actually even
know what the right number is there's
not that kind of a one-size-fits-all for
every portfolio but we know zero is not
the right number right and so you know
we're on this warpath to get every
institution in the world off of zero and
get exposure to the asset class so I
think watching that happen is really
important we've got a couple off of zero
and I think that we'll continue to do
that and there's a bunch of other people
working to do it as well but as more and
more institutions move up zero I think
it's gonna be a really important trend
to is the accreditation laws I mean I
just it's the one thing that irks me to
death is that you know in a country
where we are supposed to be kind of that
you know the the lighthouse of freedom
and prosperity etc our laws don't
reflect that right and and so it'd be
one thing if you know kind of in
practice it was hard to implement or or
something like that it's just no the law
is written in a way that prevents anyone
from
having the opportunity right and I just
I think that goes against everything
that we stand for it and it's got to
change so I think as that changes if you
know chairman Clayton said it in a very
interesting way he said look I'd love to
give more people access to these private
market opportunities while keeping the
same amount of investment protections
right so it's not giving up protections
it's just giving more access with the
same protection and so if they're able
to figure out a way to do that I think
that'll be a huge inflection point not
only for a crypto but just private
investing in general and also wealth
creation for Americans I think it's
important and then the third thing is is
outside of the US right so I think that
you know people in the Western world get
very kind of insularity thinking and
they think that you know we are the say
all be all around the world and in some
markets we are and other markets were
not and I think crypto is one of the
first times where we're seeing an
industry being created on a global scale
from day one right so you know a lot of
people the United States who had never
traveled to you know say Asia for
example and seeing you know just the the
amount of intellectual talent and energy
and capital and stuff that's being put
forward into this industry I think is
you know they just not have that
perspective and they're missing out on
how important it is there right and so
if you kind of extrapolate that back to
the US I would almost question do we
actually have enough intellectual
capital being put towards this do we
have enough you know kind of traditional
capital being put towards this and if we
don't do we fall behind is that good is
that bad right and so kind of this idea
of a geographic arbitrage around talent
capital attention regulatory issues etc
I think is going to be something that's
really important to watch and at some
point in the future may actually be
negative for the United States I don't
think the u.s. is used to being in that
position and if we get in that position
how do we respond three areas I mean
I've also focusing I would probably you
put it much better I could and a lot of
like sometimes the allocations to things
is the allocation question and you know
a lot to discuss at some point in more
detail Vanek has yon who is much smarter
than I am
and I wrote a piece on what should be to
Canada what's the right level of adding
digital assets to a portfolio and by the
way we lived through the same thing with
gold and commodities so it's an
interesting evolution totally in the
same page on on the credit accreditation
standards and kind of working on it the
International kind of realm and an
arbitrage regulatory capital or barrage
and I'm so fascinated by Asia and how
much one can learn spend a lot of time
in Europe and and and in the u.s. of
various places but AJ sort of a frontier
that we shouldn't underestimate
Singapore Japan China right now I think
probably Japan and Singapore and Vietnam
or something worth watching China is a
harder act to crack but it definitely
interesting absolutely no man listen you
guys are doing some of somebody's
Network I really appreciate your time
and I think you know all of us here are
cheering for you guys to kind of break
through on a couple of the applications
and the public markets and stuff so so
good luck and thanks so much for coming
on thank you Paul it's always a pleasure